uh when i went out yeah let's let's
check out guns shall we let's
let's let's let's check let's check out
mine jump right into it let's jump right
into it
let's check out mine and see you see
what you guys see there
oh my god all right well
we can we can ignore the filth in the
middle but um
honestly what is that sure in the middle
i don't know it's our image
okay so so so let me let me let me spell
out my three by three yeah
so from uh top left uh going down
uh row by row yeah so you've got your
name baccano
yeah fate zero evangelion orimo
log horizon one piece uh harahi or the
disappearance
and black god this screams someone who
got into anime in the 2000s
jesus christ look at this screams yeah
yeah look at this
[ __ ] black lagoon evangelion and
haruhi on the scene okay not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie i was not expecting
black lagoon to be there
i i could see it really okay so there's
nothing like it i've never heard
anything about black living coming
it's [ __ ] good no it's great i just
i'm just curious
it's it's [ __ ] brilliant it's one of
the shows that i haven't had too much of
a chance to talk about but like before
before i get into that let me let me
let me tell you the thought process
[Laughter]
let me tell you too much emotion let me
tell you the thought process i
put into like picking pictures because i
i
you know at the beginning i was like how
the [ __ ] do i pick my favorites because
i have like too many favorites right i
can talk about
right so then so nice so then i thought
okay
here's here's a big thing what if i just
pick the anime
that i have re-watched okay because if
if i've re-watched something and this is
like re-watching not for my job but
re-watching for my own enjoyment
if i've re-watched something that means
there is something
[ __ ] special about that show that has
stuck with me that i've felt like i've
wanted to go out of my way
to re-experience i agree with that and
even even on some shows that i think is
[ __ ] great like for example
like stuff like monster or like highly
critically you can claim shows i do not
want to re-watch
no no like exactly i i feel like it's
had his time in the sun
but in terms of like what i truly like
enjoy to the core
i wouldn't go out my i at the moment i
wouldn't go out and re-watch monster you
know i i wouldn't do that no okay hold
on but i get that right yeah like i'm
looking at this right now being like
yeah re-watch that re-watch that
yeah would you re-watch one piece i have
re-watched one piece is it even possible
to rewatch okay okay i've i've okay
here's the thing
i've got that stein's time machine or
some [ __ ] though how are you doing there
okay i've i've watched one piece or
basically up to up to the time skip all
the way once
and then i've rewatched it again once uh
and then i've rewatched some of my
favorites
i [ __ ] know it is and this was back
when i had time
to watch anime and i would just like
whenever i got whenever i had time
i said when you said you really watch
right i thought you were talking about
like oh i've re-watched the water seven
hours
i've re-watched alabaster i didn't think
you've already watched you've really
shown your age you need
years to re-watch that now one day no
wonder you're older than me like [ __ ] me
you need like i love how i love how you
compensate and be like no no only up
until the pre before the time
i'm like it's still like 400 episodes
okay
which is why like i was having trouble
putting a shonan on because i'm just
like
is that any shonen that i actually truly
love that i would you know
think that i would go back any time
because i was going to put you hug show
and i was thinking seven deadly sins
come
no yeah i'll come here right
but like one piece to me will go down
when it finishes will go down as
one well it already is one of the
greatest anime slash manga
yeah of course but to me when i think
back and i think back because one piece
isn't the perfect show right yeah i've
rewatched one piece
does anyone claim it is yeah no like
everyone everyone forgets about the lows
of one piece but everyone forgets about
like [ __ ]
sky allen sky island i wasn't a fan of
the foxy arc which was a filler cannon
arc that everyone doesn't talk about
you know you know what i mean what are
these names
these things don't sound [ __ ] real
was like
um it was way too long it was dragged
out to [ __ ]
but nothing in my opinion can touch
the highs of one piece when one piece is
at its best
right i i think it is the greatest
the greatest thing you can find in anime
it is i will stand by and say even
though i've
watched every minded you in anime yeah
i've cried more times watching one piece
than any other [ __ ] when you have that
many episodes something's gonna hit
right yeah like [ __ ] me but i mean
that i wasn't expecting no no i mean
like there's plenty of shows that have a
lot of episodes
yeah and haven't had the highs the one
piece has because
sam man has some dorado how do you know
anything about this
pokemon has some pretty high highs man
but like what i find amazing about one
piece is it's been going on for like
what 20 years now
almost 30 now almost like i can't
remember when it's like i think it
started in the 1990s
98 or 96 something like that yeah
but i remember i i've just caught up
with the manga with like what the wano
arc which is now one of the longest arcs
it's so long they has three parts
and it still has moments that make me
feel [ __ ] magical this is
like like one piece is like like
i watch some of the best moments in one
piece and i get reminded this is why i
[ __ ] love anime this is why i like
[ __ ] love manga
this is why i love this medium did the
author of one piece like intend for it
to be as long as it is or just like [ __ ]
it's just popular
i i i think he had planned because the
thing about one piece is that it's this
long and yet
there are there's foreshadowings that
that's happened like
[ __ ] hundreds of chapters he's not
from this planet that is
that is being explored now right and i
think he didn't expect it to be this
long
but he but when he got popular he
realized he can explore basically
every idea he that he a lot of people a
lot of people i feel kind of undermine
odor
just because it's like oh yeah you know
he made one piece but whatever it's so
long blah blah but i think
people when you look deep into it people
really undermine his skill for
storytelling because yeah i mean again
let's be honest you have to be to keep
how many how people like captivated
he's been he's been number one on shonen
jump for the past like 15 years yeah
you don't do that by luck
and like what i find amazing is it's
been going on this long and it's
not one no it's it's not only got still
got [ __ ] amazing moments in there
even in
some of the greatest uh in some of the
latest chapters and some of the latest
moments
but two no matter how far you go into
one piece
you feel like there's still an upswing
you still you still feel like he hasn't
peaked yet
yeah and like how would you write a
story that's
like almost almost a thousand chapters
long and you still think
man there's an upswing coming there's
there's something greater it's insane
every time a new
arc started yeah and i would keep up to
date with like what the manga
was saying everyone would be like how is
it that the next arc is even better yeah
how does it keep getting better
yeah how does that work well i thought
this was the peak and then it just keeps
getting down how does the hot dog stand
arc
keep just blowing me away how does the
water park adventure
supreme arc keep blowing me away right
yeah
the names don't make [ __ ] sense i
don't know it is literally that pro cd
video where he talks about anime arc
names
and like any one piece fan who's watched
that video knows that
he's just calling out one piece fans
there because we were literally talking
about this video before the podcast
started and we were just me and
me and joey was just talking about the
big marmark yeah and then connie connor
was just like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
wait that's that's a real option are you
guys serious i thought they were joking
because it was like big mom's house or
something i thought it was a
joke like that but i felt that right
like when i when i remember when i've
watched the alabaster arc in one piece
i was like this is the greatest thing
ever made yeah and then water seven came
out i was like how is that how is it
getting better and then the white beard
guys guys guys i i i hate to rush you
guys we have nine anime to talk about i
don't care
i can talk about one piece of the
[ __ ] sun because frankly i don't
really want to hear your opinions i need
you guys
i honestly do not care yeah yeah no i
already know you okay i already know
your opinions on your name i already
have amazon fate
bakano is like saying i like coming like
of course
back and i was like i like sex of course
and it's just fun
it's it's just fun and then we've we've
gushed over harihi obviously right like
how disappearance is [ __ ] amazing
horizon as well okay i'm very i'm
excited to see that yeah because like i
was thinking back to because like
obviously i'm the [ __ ] isekai man
right
i was thinking like lock horizon is the
isekai i come back to because it's it's
the only isekai i've rewatched
out of everything like re-zero i watched
because it was my job
you know what i mean that that was
literally the only reason i watched free
zero lock horizon is the only isek i've
come back to be like
man there were some good [ __ ] moments
in this and i really wanted to
re-experience some of these ideas that
well
season three is uh out yeah i'm probably
gonna have re-watching now yeah
yeah it's out this season so i'm
probably gonna read like
like verizon's the only like pure isekai
right now that i can
like recommend without it's got no catch
like it's it's not like re-zero where
it's like oh it's
it's a time loop catch you know that's
that's the interesting thing about it
localizing it's just hey guys hey guys
yeah there's a gimmick mark horizon is
just an isakai that is a just a
good iso guy no i i i i i agree it
deserves to be it has its place there
yeah i just can't get over the fact that
you unironically like orima
okay i just like for the longest time
what is urimo about i thought it was
like the chinese
incest yeah oh that's it it's it's not
about
insects it is about incest just happens
in it it's not about it there's there's
there's there's a key there's a key
[ __ ] difference between the two
there's incest in it like it's like like
a scent of a flavor
you can't just drop that in there be
like oh there's also ancestor now like
what
what do you mean is this a small thing
incest to you
it is something okay so so let me
defend in incest 4k edition i'm i'm
i'm a [ __ ] do it man i'm a [ __ ]
dude i don't care if this like
watch this clips get watch this clip get
me cancelled in like four years or like
[ __ ] four years
watch this clip again for four minutes
okay like one month
you know what i mean okay everyone
forgets that orimo
was a legitimately good [ __ ] show
when it first aired i'm gonna have to
stop you right there
it was a i'm gonna have to show you
right there
like like everyone thinks i put orimo on
the same level or something like error
manga sense say no
[ __ ] error magazine was trash from
episode one
and it knew it was trash and it it every
manga sensei is what happens
when you take all the trashiest parts of
orimo and put that and put that into a
show
orimo was a nice wholesome look at otaku
culture
and with incest and the thing is
the thing is the thing is when it was
airing everyone was just like oh yeah
this is
this is a parody of all like the incest
light novels and everything like that
right this is
this is just this is just your honor it
was but a parody yeah i i
read everything everyone thought
that it was just taking the piss out of
like you know this
the little girl emoto [ __ ] craze
happening in
in anime and level and if you if you
don't watch the final three episodes
you can watch the entire series of
series of rmo and just think that
um and then the final three episodes
happened and
it yeah that uh that that sparked an
outcry didn't it it's
it sparked an outcry right it's it's uh
it definitely uh because the the reason
the reason it sparked an outcry was
because no one was actually expecting it
yeah it went from like 20 percent incest
to
99 percent it was a hundred percent
there was there was no there was no
percentage that could be shaved off
it went full incest so and it was
unapologetic fully admit that it went
full incentive no no yeah yeah it's in
your top
nine anime because the reason it's okay
i've rewatched it because it is
re-watched it yeah yeah
i i i've already said i've rewatched
everything on this list
i don't even want to see that because
this this show like
this show is the epitome of everything i
love about trashy harry manga and anime
it's when you say that it just sounds
like satire
it is it is not sounds like sound it is
not okay so
remember when you went through my anime
list and i gave ikitosen a two
yeah so like back when i was a teenager
i was just like you couldn't appreciate
your interest
yeah yeah i'm i'm better than this fan
service [ __ ] i'm i'm better than this
trashy anime
i'm i got a good [ __ ] taste right
this is the show
that [ __ ] changed all that when i was
just like
why am i enjoying this so much why do
why do i like this
[ __ ] filth trash show i mean look
look i mean
i mean look i look i have shows like
that yeah i kissed cis being a perfect
example yeah i was about to
put it in my [ __ ] three by three
though yeah just running putting an
incess in this [ __ ] top nine yeah
i'm in the middle of the places i will
[ __ ] i
that that was a legitimate deliberate
choice i put it in the middle because
i'm just like this is
this show this single show has probably
had the biggest
overall effect on my taste in modern
anime
you literally [ __ ] made orima out to
be like the free space in a bingo card
you know
because it is yeah it is it is a [ __ ]
trashy anime right
there there are trashy moments there but
i i think
i will defend the point that oriumo
wasn't complete trash there there were
some legitimately good
heartwarming moments in there and it
wasn't complete it wasn't all trash
okay it was it wasn't our democracy it
really was okay it wasn't here
you're going to jail buddy aeromanga
sensei is ore emo reskinned
that's all it is and you have to admit
to that no i don't
you have to remember manga sensei is the
trashiest part of orimo
concentrated it is it is dense orange
you're honest
i didn't know she was 12. i'll be honest
your honor ladies and gentlemen this man
has the largest
anime youtube channel on the platform he
also this is what he said i'm
i'm [ __ ] proud of this [ __ ] i put it
i literally put this stuff
front and center and i regret that
nothing yeah
i regret [ __ ] nothing that is on my
computer now and i can't wait to use it
as blackmail